Buen día para usted Luisa Y por qué esta
jornada de huelga de trabajadores de la
salud tendrá un impacto mucho mayor en
los servicios de salud
el nivel de traumatismo que creará
aunque las enfermeras y los trabajadores
de las ambulancias han tenido diferentes
jornadas de huelgas desde finales de
2022 esta es la primera vez que paran
Juntos por ello el gran impacto y esta
huelga se considera histórica ustedes
pueden ver aquí a las enfermeras
protestando de las afueras del santo más
de los más tradicionales de Londres
apenas a cinco minutos caminando desde
el parlamento británico de unos 10 de la
oficina del Primer Ministro Richie sunat
pero la huelga de hoy es mucho más
grande se han sumado al menos 73
hospitales en toda Inglaterra y Diez mil
trabajadores de las ambulancias entre
paramédicos y conductores las enfermeras
aseguran que los tratamientos que salvan
vidas como la quimioterapia no estarían
comprometidos en el día de hoy pero los
medios reales reportan que sí el
gobierno dice que solo hoy se han
cancelado 50,000 operaciones Lo cierto
es que mañana está prevista otra jornada
de huelga de enfermeras y durante toda
esta semana huelga de diferentes
especialidades del sistema Público de
salud en el chesa un sistema que está en
cuidados intensivos hace varios años
Luisa Cuál es la posición del gobierno y
cuáles son las posibilidades de
negociación
hasta el momento el gobierno se ha
negado a reabrir esas negociaciones para
incrementos salariales que es lo que
están pidiendo las enfermeras
inicialmente han pedido un 19% el
gobierno les ha dicho que esa cifra es
imposible de cumplir especialmente en
este marco de la crisis económica que
azota al Reino Unido por ello no hay
negociaciones hasta el momento las
enfermeras le han escrito directamente
una carta al Primer Ministro para
pedirles que les haga una nueva oferta
pero hasta el momento no se ha escuchado
una respuesta por parte del alto
gobierno Lo cierto es que las enfermeras
de Escocia ilegales no están parando hoy
porque los gobiernos regionales están en
camino de llegar a un acuerdo con ellas
lo que pone muchísima más presión a
Richie sunat para que haga lo mismo aquí
en Inglaterra